[Music]
foreign
here in this video we will showcase the
differences between Shin Godzilla and
the new -1 Gojira two versions of the
king of the monsters that are built to
be scary and also enemies of humanity we
shall take a look at their sizes their
overall body design their face dorsal
plates tail legs and all just like what
we did with -1 and the monster verse
comparing one to another so let's get
into it of course let's start with size
first of all Shin Godzilla has many
forms the first one is largely unknown
in size it was around 14 meters or
something anyway it was completely
submerged and underwater with only the
tail part that was seen the second form
was underdeveloped and was small even
the third form which was kinda starting
to look like a Godzilla was only 57
meters in height or almost 187 feet the
fourth form was the biggest being almost
119 meters or 389 feet in height let's
forget the fifth form which was only 15
meters or 50 feet and product from the
tail of the larger fourth form on the
contrary Godzilla minus one aims to
resemble the original shower version in
terms of size the intention is to make
him imposing enough to be terrifying yet
not so massive that he becomes detached
from Humanity's interactions the
estimated height for this Incarnation as
shown in our previous video is
approximately 60 meters or roughly 200
feet striking a balance between
believability and the ability to engage
with people
now for coloration and scales we'll just
take a look at the fourth form of shin
Godzilla his overall coloration is
primarily black with red highlights in
between the skin of scales do not seem
to Bear resemblance to any other type of
living organism rather they look like
keloid scars and cluttered skin after a
heavy injury when a clotting has become
dark and reddish due to the hot and
black platelets it also kind of
resembles dried lava after coming out of
a volcano in contrast -1 displays an
even rougher texture characterized by a
dark brown and black color palette with
hints of gray the scales and Bunny
plates on its body appear uneven and
haphazard evoking an Eldritch aesthetic
this design incorporates a Rocky and
short appearance like reminiscent of a
nuclear Devastation notably -1 also
lacks visible guilds on his body
now let's take a look at their heads and
faces Shin's fourth form features a
rounded head with small beady eyes and
black Scott and rough skin notably this
Godzilla lacks a ton and its mouth is
filled with crooked and unusually large
teeth some of which grow outside the
flesh surrounding his mouth its lower
jog is a reminiscent of a snake capable
of opening to a disturbingly wide angle
of more than 90 degrees and even
splitting open compared to previous form
the eyes of this iteration are small and
sunken into their sockets devoid of
surrounding eyelids instead the creature
possesses silvery nictating membranes
referred to anti-flash defense membranes
that shield and Safeguard his eyes when
it shoots out the atomic breath
Additionally the neck area of shin
appears to have a muscular collar region
with fewer scars
-1 also possesses an intimidating and
ominous appearance but its facial
features resemble a hybrid of the heisei
Stan Winston's failed design and the
final walls iteration if featuring a
curved snout and a feline-like
appearance the creature's eyes are
vibrant yellow in color clearly showing
pupils and it retains a set of rows of
bony plates along the top of its head
akin to the original design its teeth
are prominently defined resembling
protruding swords fall on both the upper
and lower Jaws
now let's take a look at the dorsal
plates the fourth form of shin Godzilla
showcases dorsal plates that are larger
and black in color distinguishing it
from its previous forms its previous
third and second forms these plates also
feature red scales reminiscent of keloid
scars they are numerous a relatively
even in size along the creature's back
but when compared to the other
Godzilla's iterations they are
comparatively smaller in overall size in
contrast -1's dorsal plate stand out as
the most significant difference from it
with other Godzilla designs they deviate
from the traditional Maple Leaf shape
although certain elements of it can
still be seen or observed instead minus
ones uh dorsal plates resemble enormous
Thorns or swords tips emerging from a
central stem this unique design Choice
aims to enhance the creature's
horrifying appearance with every aspect
of its body conveying a sense of death
and destruction these in comparison to
Shin's flatter and smaller plates
further emphasize -1 distinctiveness
now we come to the arms and the legs
Shin's fourth forms arms have undergone
some development some compared to its
previous forms however they remain
notably small and do not extend
significantly beyond the chests the
creature's chest with four digits they
resemble underdeveloped or baby-like
limbs on the other hand the legs are
larger and more muscular providing
greater strength and support but it
still moves at a relatively slow speed
interestingly Shin Godzilla's feet
feature numerous small vestigial toe
claws emerging from both the top and the
sides in addition to the five main
digits minus one Godzilla showcases
massive robots legs that draw
inspiration from the design of Godzilla
in singular points these legs maintain a
dinosaur in appearance and and lean
towards more of a theropod-like
structure and has four toes with long
black claws his arms are small in size
relative to the feet but still are
bigger than Shin's hands and the hands
possess eagle-like talents meant for
devil station and killing the arms do
look to be more well developed and more
muscular though
now what about a tail Shin Godzilla
possesses an elongated tail adorned with
small spiked like dorsal plates spanning
its entire length the tip of the tail is
depicted as red and bloody with twisted
and mangled bones forming a skeletal
structure resembling a spare head at the
end the Tail's length is nearly twice
that of the entire body and features
three rows of hundreds of minuscule and
dorsal plate like osteaderms along the
upper section
-1 Godzilla's tail begins as a thick and
sturdy appendage maintaining a
consistent thickness throughout its
entire length although gradually
tapering towards the end the tail takes
on a tube-like appearance covered in
thorny scales and plates the Tail's end
point is surrounded in shape but doesn't
have the skeletal structure at the end
like shins the part where the fifth form
start to emerge from before being put
into stasis that is
next we'll take a look at the underbelly
much like his entire body Shin's inner
sides align with scales that appear to
look like keloid scars and heavy blood
clotting these however are line or
segmented throughout the inner body
region this Godzilla possesses a notable
chest with a prominent sternum that is
shaped like an ax head featuring a
pointed structure a kind of like visible
ribs on the side as well
-1 maintains the same rough and uneven
scaly texture throughout its body
extending even to the undersides however
the sting Rose segmentations are
observed near its pelvic region in
contrast the creature's chest resembles
two enormous spectral muscles that
exhibit severe third degree burns and he
also appears to be encrusted with
hardened rock-like formations
lastly let's take a look at their
personalities initially Shin Godzilla
appears passive and seemingly unaware of
humanity he inadvertently causes
destruction due to the nature of his
earlier forms just being clumsy and
later due to his sheer size he barely
acknowledged the military assaults on
him at first however when he was hit
with bunker Buster bombs causing injury
he becomes enraged and retaliates with
his devastating Atomic Powers this shows
that Shin was actually indifferent to
humanity and only reacted as a defense
mechanism here's the embodiment of a
hyper-evolving life form with no
emotions or feelings a creature
absolutely alien to humanity while at
the same time being a destructive force
of nature while limited information is
available about -1 Godzilla's
personality it is evident that he will
embody a destructive force rather than
harboring any empathy towards Humanity
portrayed as a monster that evokes
horror elements minus one will
unquestionably be viewed as an
antagonist and an evil entity by
Humanity
so those are the differences between
Shin Godzilla and minus one Godzilla
anyway I hope you have enjoyed watching
this video do hit the like button for
support and subscribe to push us through
the YouTube algorithm but most of all
smash that Bell icon for regular updates
and new videos like this one here on
this channel take care fam